[Music]
hi it's Michelle from Lab muffin Beauty
science here skincare nerd chemistry PhD
and big fan of guacamole with extra
lemon juice lemon is awesome in food but
today I'm going to be talking about the
science of why lemon belongs in your
body and not on your body if you like
this sort of video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to my channel and click the
notification bell to make sure you don't
miss any of my videos if you've ever
been on Pinterest you'll know that
there's tons and tons of DIY skincare
recipes a lot of them use common kitchen
ingredients and one of the most popular
ones is lemon juice
you'll find it in tons of hair and skin
recipes these recipes claim that lemon
juice does tons and tons of different
things it will brighten skin or lighten
pigmentation it'll clear up your
breakouts and reduce oil production
exfoliate your skin and reduce wrinkles
it will get rid of blackheads or reduce
your debt it will solve global warming
lemon is cheap and it smells really nice
but is it effective and more importantly
is that safe let's talk about the
science behind lemon juice let's start
by talking about the chemicals inside
lemon juice there is a bit of truth
about all of these amazing claims about
what lemon juice can do lemon juice does
contain a lot of ingredients that are
used in skincare as the Pinterest DIY
recipes will say lemon contains vitamin
C in the form of ascorbic acid ascorbic
acid is a fantastic ingredient for
evening out pigmentation ascorbic acid
is an antioxidant which prevents free
radical damage and so it can help with
sun damage also known as photo aging and
wrinkles ascorbic acid can also
potentially increase the collagen in
your skin which will make a plumper and
less prone to wrinkling
there's also citric acid which is an
alpha hydroxy acid or a a alpha hydroxy
acids will exfoliate your skin I have
talked about them before in my video on
exfoliation there's also a free
exfoliation guide that I've put together
that you can download if you want to
find out more about exfoliation chemical
exfoliants like alpha hydroxy acids can
with acne and aging they can give you
plumper smoother brighter skin another
one of the components of lemon juice is
niacin which is a form of vitamin b3 you
might know it better in the form of
niacin amide it's an anti-inflammatory
that helps with pigmentation and it
helps with dry skin as well so
theoretically your lemon juice could be
great for your skin but of course
there's a catch
so don't rub a lemon on your face yet an
important question we have to ask is
what is the strength of each of these
ingredients in the lemon juice one of
the problems with natural ingredients is
that there's lots of variation about
what chemicals are actually in there the
exact components will vary with things
like season locations so where it's
grown how fresh the extract is how ripe
it was when it was harvested how it's
been stored
whether it's wim refrigerated or not
whether it's been left in the Sun I've
talked about some of these issues in my
video on natural skincare but let's have
a look at what's in a typical lemon
it's got somewhere around forty four
point five milligrams of ascorbic acid
per hundred mils of lemon juice this
translates to naught point naught four
percent there's about five percent
citric acid and there's naught point
naught naught naught 1 percent niacin if
we compare these percentages to what's
in a formulated skincare product
normally you'll see ascorbic acid and
vitamin C serums at about five to 20
percent alpha hydroxy acids will be true
to fifteen percent and niacin amide will
be two to ten percent so you can see
that the dose of these ingredients in
our lemon juice is pretty low compared
to in a properly formulated skincare
product apart from the citric acid what
this means is that you're not really
getting enough of these ingredients on
your skin through lemon juice to make a
big difference it's not going to be a
great substitute for a regular skincare
product
so in terms of effectiveness lemon juice
is probably not that great
[Music]
we also need to talk about safety
lemons contain millions of other
chemicals apart from these ones that we
know are good in skincare that's because
most things in nature are complex
mixtures
they haven't been purified yet one of
the biggest issues about lemon juice is
that it contains photoshot sick
chemicals these are called saralyn's
which are a subset of furanocoumarins or
fewer coumarins these chemicals are
found in many citrus peels including
lemon and lime if you're squeezing a
lemon at home you can't really separate
the juice from these phototoxic
components these Fiorano coumarins also
found in parsnips celery parsley and
figs the problem is that when they're on
your skin they react with UV to cause
something called Phytophthora dermatitis
in other words a skin reaction caused by
plants when it interacts with sunlight
the symptoms of red skin and horrific
blistering that develops over the next
48 hours after light exposure there's
going to be some really gross blisters
coming up so look away now if you're
squeamish
it's over the blisters are gone oh it's
okay it's okay
it's not entirely clear what the exact
mechanism of how these chemicals caused
this massive blistering on your skin
either they react with DNA took form
cross links or they interact with
proteins in your skin which causes your
keratinocytes or skin cells to die and
your membrane start rupturing the
overall process leads to damage cell
membranes which results in cell death
edema which is swelling blistering and
injury to your skins after this reaction
you might get post inflammatory
hyperpigmentation which is pigmentation
after damage and this can take months to
heal in proper skin care products a lot
of the time the citrus essential oils
have been processed to remove these
photo toxic chemicals but this doesn't
happen if you giy another scary possible
side effect is something called chemical
leuco derma this is when your skin gets
gee pigmented in other words you get
uneven areas of faded pigment there's
been a few reports in the literature of
this chemical leuco journal for example
one woman used a lemon toner for three
months on her face and so you can see
the areas where there's been
hyperpigmentation in other words less
pigment than there should be in another
instance someone rubbed a lemon on their
face for five days their skin became
really irritated it scaled up the skin
exfoliated and then they got lesions
these lesions healed after about five
days but it left gee pigmented patches
this doesn't seem to be an allergic
reaction it's some sort of toxic
reaction and it could be partly because
lemon juice has quite a low pH in other
words it's very acidic it has a pH of
about true
[Music]
so we assumed at the start that lemon
juice was cheap but isn't really in
Australia citric acid is two dollars 25
475 grams
whereas lemons are currently a dollar
seventy eight each each lemon contains
thirty to forty five mils of juice five
percent converts to one point five to
two point two five grams of citric acid
so 75 grams would be sixty to eighty
nine dollars it's actually way cheaper
to go out and buy citric acid and
dissolve it in water than to use lemon
juice plus you avoid the throat Oh
toxicity I still probably wouldn't
recommend it because the pH would still
be quite low so even if you avoided the
light induced blisters you could still
get the hyperpigmentation and citric
acid is quite large so it will work
better in a properly formulated product
designed for skin
if we compare lemon juice with properly
formulated products it isn't that cheap
either
since citric acid isn't that popular in
exfoliants I'm comparing it against
other alpha hydroxy acids like glycolic
and lactic acid and I've converted them
so we're comparing the same number of
molecules of each type of áááá as you
can see if there are some products that
are quite comparable in price plus
there's even a couple that are cheaper
these products have a lot of added
benefits for example a lot of them have
antioxidants plus they're in a base that
will help the alpha hydroxy acids
penetrate and work now there's the
concept that the dose makes the poison
so lemon juice might not always be
unsafe but I wouldn't recommend using it
and leave on recipes with large amounts
of lemon juice in wash off recipes or
recipes were really small amounts of
lemon juice it might be fine it's still
a lot safer to use a product that's been
specifically formulated to go on your
skin if you're still determined to use
lemon juice then I highly recommend that
you only use wash-off recipes with
really small amounts of lemon juice and
to immediately stop if you get
irritation or if you see any pigment
changes you should also wash it off
really thoroughly before you go out into
the Sun and use sunscreen I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked it
please give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to my channel
more videos like this you can also
follow me on Instagram and check out my
blog for tons more beauty science see
you next time
you